What was the turning point for you coming back and winning?
I mean, for me, I just thought it would be very embarrassing to lose this in under an hour...
...so I just have to try as hard as I can...
...and stop having a really bad attitude.
You said from the beginning you had seven matches, seven masks, seven names.
What was the message you wanted to send, Naomi?
Well, what was the message that you got...
...was more the question. I feel like the point is to make people start talking.
What were you most gratified about the awareness that you raised?
I mean, for me, I've been inside of the bubble...
...so I'm not really sure what's really going on in the outside world.
All I can tell is what's going on on social media...
..and for me, I feel like, you know, the more retweets it gets...
...or that's so lame but, you know, the more people talk about it.
What are you most proud of about your time here in New York?
Me, I think i fought for every match starting with the Cincinnati Tournament...
...leading up to here, so.
Congratulations, the champion of the 2020 US Open, Naomi Osaka.
Please, Naomi, lift up your trophy.